lord
sochaux
the perfume
m
the cynic
I
we have
no
you
knee
there
he
I
I suddenly
text
this
but
if we say
s
ham
we
the thing
yes
and it's good for him
it's
the nights I say  that
chivu
more
laurie
december
he
I
the measure is normal
ok
no
less people
it's him
they are almost
thirty children from the villages
I
this
we follow
I
his part
no
to
between us
I life
later
who
nicolas
there
more
he
I  will answer
example
for
m
him
yes
if in 10
[Music]
this time it's going to
impressed him by e-mail
market
go see no one
the way
no
paradise
where
simple
there
in the world
for
the good days his friends after
we received  this morning madam president
the function of the european union
accompanied by the 22 commissioners for
our 10th meeting that the japanese to
someone from the european union
when we see there the size of the
european delegation
it denotes  the depth of our
antenna for life thank you once again
madam in the president
we had interviews with our
collaborators who are currently
in different branches all
different aspects of our partnership
and I also had the opportunity to
meet madam president
in a previous study we had
mentioned subjects which are fundamental
in its legs and swamps which
constitute the pillars of our work
on questions of peace and security
you know that the european union is the
main partner through the
peace and security facility
we work together in
different theaters notably in the sahel
in the lake basin and in the horn
of africa in somalia we have
common concerns where as
regards libya unfortunately the
war continues for the ceasefire
and lampard or are not  not yet
respected but we do not lose
hope we will work with the
united nations
the other partners to
achieve peace in this country in which there
will never be a military solution
he knows where I returned last night since
then she is also present
in particular in the alliance that in the face of
the commissioner in charge of questions
partners were also
present at other things in the lake basin
chad and danish the european union
supports sending zionism national duty
on trade
and investment issues i knew that black
african has launched one of the biggest
projects  in its deliberate
continental luck and which is supported
strongly not from a europe and the
mentalist in the long run to this area located
at one of the largest markets in the
world
it is naturally since the
european union and our
main trading partner
i believe  that this is an issue that
interests us both and we are
working together
the issue of climate change
is a concern  major pation
yes two continents knew that
desertification drought
the drying up of the poles of the phenomena
that the union makes of the plains which is the
African continent and Europe
and Africa is due to the implementation of
the detailed agreement which  is nevertheless an
agreement which for you and is fundamental
the more than to start the adaptation
the problem does not stop
only adaptation it is necessary because mass January
to publish renewable energies
and on its side also the traffic
have  committed to working together to
preserve the planet
this is something that takes
what we think and is fundamental
of course we discussed
operational issues development issues
we insisted on the need to
strengthen multilateralism in a
world that is beginning  to worry
about these various issues and you
know the African continent which has more
than a billion inhabitants, the
majority of whom are young d  so the question
of youth
the question of women are essential
for the economic and
social development of this continent
of course something that is
forgotten and from German to that it is the
question of
migration migration is essentially internal
has arrived in  African land the there are
also the young people who
sometimes cross at the risk of their life the who
are outside of this issue
also must be strict and from
continent to continent between our two
organizations
I believe that we have made significant steps
in our discussions
continue  we will still have several
appointments taking you to the ministerial level
dated is the daughter and end of the
sixth africa europe summit which
reduced to bxl these are important appointments
which can allow us
to further refine this very
important partnership I know that the  europe is preparing
a saas is true j strategy for the
girl and i think these interviews
have enabled us  allow those
who will follow to have a
common approach for a reinforcement of montreux
by canadian even if madam hours
[Music]
it was common law and not towards
the death of a patient is a woman
yes but as they are africans
we  in find
[Music]
ten candidates
elisabeth moss no matter where she is
africanews member states to defender or
as i designed for 18 m eur the
specter of a blockage and is to fight and
innovation innovation of this
weasel casting and ironic roman case  we
are all there success because of touba
swing aux terrines de berlioz between
hamad ben spies fritsch wade barrett
team project hope you need is faster
than they did is at the limit the whole
spectrum hoping to speak to business
community in the state investments and
technology
north field of nodes we have no win
technology in fine all here like
cash in walk the gender and devastate
gave me a moderate drop in the casino
is present fine mousseli  ne and a
daughter lucia dahlab in any case faced with the
steps spare favor and
rapists last party to text of trade
pont à vendin can be strong here we
have a dynamic and very
old partner the figures show it the
vitality of its social partners
camille that he is of course on a
certain number of questions which are on
the table in the group to take into
account points of divergence on
which we do not have the same
approach in any case for the moment
and he is completely  obvious as
a sincere partner in the discussions of
all the questions there are questions
which federate which have a cultural dimension
it is necessary to wait for four religious meters
and on which we each have our
position so it is completely normal
that in a partnership like the  belly
it can never be that
we agree on everything but that does not
mean that we must not continue to
discuss we must not talk about
it that's what they have  wanted to
signify this morning cause
up to 110 x pect pressure
hey it's over
a catchy headline expressing his
gratitude to all made a single access
customs and a trade in the hockey news
a man in chains sector everything stay
humble respectful continent  big think
they came change of image
kelly to you for windows to fear this
street but djawad province because we are
benchmarks for be good trip is a
close
we are organizations we
present them two continents which are very
close
historically on graphically
commercially we have  values
e each have our own identity it go
s without saying that when there is a probl
m it is first necessary that people who a
e interested deal with their probl
ms and had wondered if this requi
es the support of their friends of their partn
rs therefore  for the African solutions to the
African problems
is obvious I will confess to you that we have
observed in Libya for example
today states which are
in  ended by inviting four themes as
much as I could have read who for once
cannot even that they have committed he does not
lose by interpreting the decision of
the Security Council having invented a
regime that has created chaos in
which we live
so we  believe that partnerships
is absolutely using his father let's
discuss with our friends from around the world
but there are a number of things
that are handled by the Africans
themselves and it is up to the Africans themselves
if they feel they have the support or  their
convergence with talent
a part of the world that's the essence
of African solutions to African problems
, of which, as the presidency said,
it is not a question of imposing a
model on another society which serves
absolutely incomprehensible attempts
springs  his tale disorganization equal
like friends like partners
there are subjects that we have in
common there are values that we have in co
mon and there are challenges that are to th
other challenges of the together  emblems of the
test climate issues for
example these commercial issues so let's
work in a dynamic way and
that's what makes everyone while living
their difference but we have an
important field in which we operate
and behind for the benefit of our two
continents which  concerns
4 pin expectations center and tucuman
resolution of agban houses fifty-five of
funk punk masonic rites
missing men these women all and all and
that all vote and sakhr el materi which
tend to stagnate
because in the light and had
only warm giuly  atmos stop and amine in
baghdad
the crisis i'm losing someone even the
sorting of goods bild that won't go
the arms embargo has been decided that a man
who never silenced the guns arrive
all carried by sea by  the air
by road
the ceasefire has not been applied
we were madam president and
myself present in berlin which we believed
is a great hope because the
permanent members  members of the
security council were all present and at
the highest level
the states which support the parties in
conflict are also present audio
limits and important resolutions
have been taken internet but which
unfortunately until today
are not yet supported the  cease
fire was quoted to the donations that we thought that
the plebs had returned cease fire
which is not obvious it is true that
we intend to send delegations to
geneva but until then the project have
separated for  consultation whose embargo
is not observed the seasons of the two
conditions which can allow to
initiate a political process of
reconciliation
it is for example decided that the
African union must take charge of
the organization of a conference of
conciliation  inclusive between the Libyan parties it is
still necessary that the war is what
we give the possibility to the Libyans
to be able to meet to be able to
discuss their problems
so there is re  a serious challenge to
the international community on the
question of goods
I hope that all the actors have given so much
need because there is no
solution it is absolutely necessary to give the
possibility for the goods on their part
and we know who  brings the weapons which brings
even the shadows currently must
respect international law must
respect the decisions
difficulty it is even a question of the credibility
of the multilateral system internationals that
this is respected are content with the
possibility of negotiations to
have a political solution alive
the  lyonnais continue they fall
back a zone of continental in 2000
francs of titles soul said m john huston
our faith task all his team 6
million by lisa brother of a soldier at the
quick news is what is late
hamdani is conducted on meetic round table
of a fine flower bars in 2d marine
activity does not stop at pigeons at the
news of the world
the dwellings are grosso mensah of
inve  stors europe said dan la frans
motif at shimane it be big bucks
but alone 10:30 11:2 a.m.
i did not live well to try it and
a house that i said what i said
in our  camp but that's sometimes
it's a major project for the
African continent of projects to do it has the advantage
of creating a market of more than a
billion inhabitants so all African countries
suffer from this area of
free trade
so it is an advantage for
African states and their
partners Europe being
the first and oldest economic partner
I believe it is also an advantage to
support the establishment of this market
effectively in the other country where it is  there have
been abuses of the economic partnership agreements
but all gone we have a
more inclusive framework that must be supported
and which will sort out this dynamic I believe
in commercial relations
in this report
with a feature on the functions not be
forgotten the corpse was  to a destiny of
new richmond rich  mond and company
fell during yescher de fact dacha and
dany boon no longer respects major defect
is recognized of plant species are
they all fighters dozens of europe
in the words words in training
logistics training
[Music]
michael jordan staal defender worse for
small errors in his
destroyer thesis when luigi something
wauquiez his body the
African continent has become a breeding ground for
terrorism everyone today knows
that tourism is a threat to international peace
and security
what is  happened in libya with its
consequences on the greenhouses is known
is known so is all of libya i
would like to thank germany
chancellor merkel took this
initiative after several weapons and the
last time seemed to us practically
like i educated two  protagonists
were there
unfortunately until then I hope do
n't lose hope
I hope you are conclusions of the
jacks who suffer  t was also
adopted a resolution of the
security council can allow that we
really attack the resolution of
the kitchen because we all witnessed
a war by proxy
roxio in libya the parties are known
what supports it from  its course
it must stop by respecting the
decisions that were taken
herbert same as those taken
by the security council
where europe has supported and continue to
support north africans that it has been
in somalia for more than  ten years we had
to counter chabal that this evening in
the lake chad basin where the international mixed force
that the g5 sahel were
African initiatives in time to be
able to face the terrorist threat
there also we had the support
of the drops
I  came back to see from where instead of three
where the sixth summit of the g 500
m was held
and there at the alliance counted only an
alliance for the sahel in which
the european union plays an
important role I can  nse that the threat was
gray city global threat
the proximity between europe and africa
commands us to work together
to be able to face this sad
reality
we were also at
united nations level to ensure that, for
example, the forces of the  g5 be given a
mandate that chapter 7 and that they
have the means because it is a
threat to peace and international security
and that of the kind
of security council of the united nations we
must work because  as many
coalitions have been organized in the near
east to fight against
terrorists
the Islamic state I think that it perished there
in this part of africa and it
necessarily takes the same mobilization
are separated against this phenomenon which is
gaining momentum  magnitude and which is
extremely dangerous extremely
violent and seeking to
destabilize peace to security not only an
opinion but overall
[Music]
here it is